so scott thank you very much for
visiting us virtually uh scott
williamson is a
is a political scientist and
he's in the department of social
political sciences at bocconi
and today we'll um hear about uh
people's um
perceptions and attitudes towards uh
migrants um and
you know scott so
you know you're like we discussed you're
in a interdisciplinary audience and this
seminar is generally very
interdisciplinary so last week we had
anthropology speaking the previous week
an economist speaking
and and so we tend to get participation
from people in different disciplines
and you know and sometimes you know of
course disciplinary uh
like
cultures vary and sometimes you know
people might
um just
unmute themselves and ask a question if
there's something
like clarifying they wanna they wanna
hear
all right ah thank you please take it
away
oh and uh
teresa teresa also wanted me to announce
that we're now doing a survey on the
seminars and she'll put the link in the
chat so if the participants can
you can just uh click and
provide us your feedback
thank you
great thanks so much um thank you for
those of you who are here thank you to
the program for the opportunity to share
my work the title of the project is
combining perspective getting with
information delivery to increase public
support for refugees
um this is joint work with a team of
scholars who have worked with previously
on related projects um clara adida and
lauren father at ucsd adeline lowe at
university of wisconsin-madison
and molina platas at
new york university abu dhabi
so i'm very lucky to
be working with them and we all look
forward to any feedback you might have
and i'm completely happy to take
questions throughout so please feel free
to interrupt me
at any point if something's unclear or
if um you want to ask a clarifying
question
uh let's see okay so i want to start by
just
noting the extent to which for the past
several decades or really since we have
public opinion data
the american public has generally been
opposed to welcoming refugees or
specific policies designed to bring in
specific refugees from specific
conflicts even those in which the united
states has been very much involved um so
we have evidence on this from world war
ii with jewish refugees from nazi
germany um but then also from hungary in
1958 following the vietnam war um in the
late 1970s
uh with cuba in 1980 and then less so
but um in 1990s with ethnic albanians
but the general pattern here is one in
which
opposition to refugees has historically
been
relatively high
and we've seen this very much continue
into more recent conflicts
most notably with syria so from polling
by gallup in
2015 at the height of the syrian refugee
crisis uh 37 of respondents
um approved of welcoming in more syrian
refugees but a fairly large majority
disapprove uh so this is a consistent
pattern that we see over and over um
this did change to some extent following
the election of president trump when
actually americans over those four years
became more willing to endorse
immigration and the admittance of
refugees specifically but what we did
see which wasn't really as pronounced in
recent years was a growing partisan gap
between republicans and democrats so
over this period democrats became more
supportive and republicans
tended to become more opposed to
admitting refugees
and these attitudes are very much
reflected in
the politics and policies surrounding
this issue so specifically with
republicans becoming more opposed we saw
around this time as i'm sure you're
aware
that republican governors were resisting
efforts to settle syrians in their
states
and of course infamously donald trump's
muslim ban was proposed in
2015 during the presidential campaign
then following the san bernardino
attacks but also linked to these
arguments about whether or not to um
admit refugees from syria so we do see
that this public opinion seems to drive
to some extent policy
on this issue
and what's also quite common is to see
that when politicians are justifying
these sorts of policies there's a lot of
misinformation that gets trafficked um
in attempting to persuade americans to
be more restrictive in terms of
immigration or refugees so again
trump's executive order or muslim ban
was implemented in some fashion and the
way this was justified was to talk about
how
in part how refugees or those coming to
the u.s often don't get vetted very much
at all and so who knows who's coming in
who knows what kinds of threats they
might pose and of course this is
completely false in terms of how the us
goes about vetting uh refugees
especially um but this was a cornerstone
of the policy and even recently
uh we saw this with um the 2021
refugee wave of afghans coming to the
united states following the fall of
kabul um when former president trump at
the time claimed that there is no
vetting of refugees coming to
america from afghanistan and again this
was very much false
in this specific case it doesn't seem to
have been very successful because this
was
a period in which americans were more
willing to support admitting afghans
so with all this prevalence of
misinformation often used to justify and
promote
anti-refugee sentiment
one common strategy that seems common
sense
for advocates and activists is to
publish information trying to correct
these misconceptions in a very factual
way
so this is an example of one such
article from human rights first in 2016
where they say top three myths about the
u.s refugee resettlement system
dispelled um and then they go through
those in quite a lot of detail
um and so in this project the primary
motivating question is whether and in
what context the provision of this sort
of correcting information uh can
actually change recipients
misconceptions and so the first order
question here is um when you provide
this sort of factual information do you
actually see individuals update and um
correct their
false views
but then second and perhaps more
importantly we're interested in whether
this correction of information has
broader spillover benefits to reducing
prejudice and negative attitudes towards
out groups in this case refugees
specifically
so you might think that when you correct
this misconception about betting
and the extent to which refugees are
looked at very closely by the u.s
government that people might become less
worried about security concerns and that
this would then spill over into their
hostility towards refugees perhaps their
preferences even on refugee policies and
maybe even their willingness to take
action on behalf
of refugees coming to the united states
and then finally providing information
in this way is only one strategy that
advocates have used and that scholars
have studied in terms of trying to
reduce prejudice towards out groups
and
one other common basket of strategies
ties to leverage empathy specifically to
generate empathy for out groups and
reduce prejudice in that way and so
we're also interested in comparing the
relative effectiveness of information
provision relative to these um empathy
strategies
so talking a little more about
um why information
might fail to
uh or it might
what the literature says about this
information correction um in general
moving away from prejudice production
for a minute we do find that people tend
to update uh false falsely held beliefs
when it is corrected
but when this starts to get political or
tied into
um issues of controversy that becomes
less the case and one area in which that
is true is with prejudice reduction
and we have research on this question
about immigrants and refugees
specifically finding mixed results in
line with that broader pattern
so facini had all for instance do show
large positive effects of information
about
how
immigrants would benefit japan's aging
workforce
on japanese citizens
attitudes and support towards
more immigration but that tends to be a
bit of an outlier other studies for
instance adidas show that when you tell
americans how little relatively speaking
their country did to welcome syrian
refugees um this doesn't actually
convince them that the u.s should be
doing more
um likewise sides and citroen um show
that the
um when you correct people's
misperceptions about how many immigrants
there are in the united states which we
might think would be linked to
how threatening they perceive immigrants
to be that this doesn't actually have
much spillover into how they view
immigrants or immigration policy
so there are three reasons in thinking
through these mixed findings for
why this information provision may fail
to shift attitudes because of course
there are all sorts of different
information pieces of information that
you can provide people with and so the
first may be that the facts are just
already known to individuals maybe they
won't even
admit that but they already know what
you're trying to correct and so it's
just not that helpful
um
the second is that the facts are new you
are changing the way they think about
something but
it's not actually relevant to how they
form attitudes towards an out group for
instance or the behaviors they might
take towards that group as well so if it
is one of these two reasons that
generally explains the the null effects
i just mentioned
then finding the kind of correct
information
in the right context would be an
effective strategy to perhaps increase
favorability towards
um refugees but of course there is a
third possibility for which we have a
lot of evidence in other contexts which
is that maybe the facts are new and they
are relevant but individuals biases in
terms of how they process information
causes them to resist actually believing
this new information or to incorporate
it into how they're thinking about these
groups and if this is generally
widespread then
we might not find this strategy to be
particularly effective
there's another
possible problem here that we wanted to
flag which is that correcting
information in some cases may be
counterproductive if it ends up finding
threats
and getting people to think about
concerns they wouldn't otherwise have
have thought about
so if we think about information
informational interventions
that are often used by advocates or
politicians talking about refugees
they often cite the economic
contributions that refugees make to the
united states for instance
or the fact that there is very low
security risk from bringing refugees in
but in doing this you may actually
inadvertently raise the salience
of potential economic and security
concerns or perhaps people will think
that
others are concerned about this maybe i
should be too
so i don't want to pick on anyone
specifically here but i think this
infographic on the slide is a pretty
good example of something that could
have this sort of effect
so here they say refugees are economic
contributors clearly trying to address
the potential concerns someone might
have that refugees come to the country
and then
subsist on government support
et cetera don't actually help the
economy and so they say the top three
industries that employ refugees are
manufacturing the health sector and
general services
but in looking at this it's possible we
don't know but it's possible that
someone would be well okay maybe
refugees are then competing with
americans for jobs in these very
important
industries and so you've actually primed
a an economic threat concern
that ends up being counterproductive
so setting this information provision
aside for a second
another set of strategies as i mentioned
for trying to
reduce prejudice or increase inclusive
attitudes and behaviors is to leverage
emotion
and specifically empathy towards a
member of the out group to then have
that
broaden into more inclusive attitudes
more generally
so there's a large body of research
showing that this tends to be quite
effective including
with regards to attitudes towards
refugees and immigrants specifically
so again adidas all show that if you
encourage people to take the perspective
of a refugee fleeing from syria that
this might increase their willingness to
write a letter to the white house
advocating for lifting the refugee cap
likewise brockman and kala show that if
you give people the perspective of an
unauthorized immigrant show them what
it's like to be in that position um that
this can reduce negative attitudes
towards this group as well uh in part by
creating more empathy for their
situation
and then work that i've done with this
these same co-authors as well as some
others shows that priming people on
their own families histories with
migration
can also trigger empathy towards
migrants today and perhaps then shape
the way they view
immigrants and immigration policy
so we in this study wanted to build on
this work with with two questions and
i'll talk a little more about these in a
minute but the first was whether there
might be beneficial interactions between
providing information to correct a
misconception
and also generating empathy in the same
sort of intervention prejudice reduction
intervention so if we use these in
tandem does that actually
create better results and then the
second is thinking about how these
empathy generating interventions may
work
more or less effectively with certain
types of people and specifically whether
individuals who just
tend to be more empathetic in general
respond more or less to these kinds of
interventions
so on the first question um again the
idea here is are there interactions
between providing information um and
then trying to also do this perspective
taking or perspective getting to
generate empathy and what we expected
going into this project is that if you
embed information correction in an
empathy-inducing narrative that this
might help guard against the negative
externalities of information that i just
discussed where you might inadvertently
prime threats um but also then help with
information updating so get people to
open up and accept um that their beliefs
were inaccurate and they update and then
perhaps actually incorporate that into
how they're thinking about refugees more
generally um
and there are two reasons that in our
mind this may have this this may have
occurred so the first is that emotions
do affect how individuals integrate new
information
into into their attitudes um this recent
paper for instance shows that when
people get angry they're less likely to
accept new information that corrects a
misconception
and that this has effects on their
political
views and the second is that
the cognitive demand of taking someone
else's perspective or at least
reflecting on it can reduce reliance on
stereotyping
and so in this case when people get
information that counters a stereotype
or misconception they have
they might be more likely to then apply
that
information and update their views and
so these two mechanisms to us suggested
that it might be possible to
essentially turn information provision
into a more consistent effective
prejudice reduction strategy by pairing
it with
um a narrative that at the same time
generates empathy for a member of the
out group
on the second question which is again
whether these empathy generating
interventions um are more or less
effective for individuals who have
higher or lower baseline empathy we went
into this with somewhat ambiguous
expectations for
what might happen
so there's actually research showing
that individuals with higher levels of
empathy who just tend to feel more
empathetic towards others
on a day-to-day basis
might actually have more empathy
specifically for in-group members
because those are the people they relate
most closely to and so when they're
feeling empathetic that's mostly
directed towards um someone they can
relate to most closely and this might
actually have negative consequences for
intergroup relations um if that empathy
for their in-group then essentially
causes negative views of the out-group
that they might perceive to be
threatening their in-group members
and in this case it may be that when you
try to generate empathy through these
other interventions
there's somewhat of a boomerang where
that empathy instead gets directed
towards the in group and then these
these interventions are actually less
effective for those with higher levels
of baseline empathy
on the other hand if you are someone who
is just generally more empathetic
that's probably going to
make you better at thinking about what
it would be like to be in someone else's
shoes
and the ability to do that might then
create
more openness to
updating your views of out group members
and in that case we might expect that
these sorts of interventions are
actually more effective
among individuals with a higher baseline
level
of
empathy
so just to step back and summarize then
what we're
trying to do in this study um we're
first interested in seeing if we can
identify misconceptions that are
actually relevant to how americans
develop their attitudes towards refugees
so find that information that people
don't really know um and that also
should have an impact on their views of
the refugee population in the us
and then to see if in correcting that
misconception
we can first
actually get them to update their false
view and then second try
more generally to have that spill over
into prejudice reduction
and an improvement of attitudes towards
uh towards refugees
and then the third is whether we can
make that even more effective again by
essentially shielding the information in
an empathy intervention so looking for
that interaction between
this information uh provision and using
perspective getting
and then finally looking at that
heterogeneous treatment effect so does
this empathy treatment also work more or
less well
based on how much empathy someone has in
general
so um any questions at this point before
i get into the design
okay um so yeah feel free to interrupt
if anything comes up
uh so we try to answer these questions
through two surveys that were done two
years apart
um the first in the fall of 2019 with an
approximately 3 500.
um and the second in the fall of 2021 so
just recently um with an n of
approximately 9 000. these were not
panel surveys so these are not the same
individuals
but they are um samples recruited
through lucid which provides
um scholars with an easy tool to
um
get surveys done online we fielded this
through qualtrics online
and their
representative of the american
population on key demographic
characteristics age gender income
ethnicity education region
and partisanship um so these are not the
highest quality nationally
representative samples but they are
representative on certain
characteristics that hopefully let us
draw some conclusions
from a gener to generalize to the
american population broadly
the first study was intended to measure
baseline knowledge and attitudes
of respondents
about refugees as well as immigrants in
the united states and as i alluded to
the goal here was to identify important
misconceptions about refugees so
we use this first survey to simply see
if there are certain areas in which
people are particularly likely to be
misinformed about what the refugee
population looks like in the united
states
and then the second study
included our information correction
experiments along with that empathy
intervention
trying to build from the first study to
see if correcting the misinformation
from study one
actually has beneficial effects on views
of refugees
so i'll somewhat briefly go over the
results from the first study
um this is a table showing
some of the questions we asked in terms
of trying to get people to at least
guess or say what they thought
the refugee population in the u.s looks
like
so in terms of how many refugees were
admitted um
that year
the median response was 20 000 and
that's actually remarkably close to the
actual number which was around 20 22 000
in 2019
um in terms of the percent of refugees
coming into the united states united
states where women and children
it's a slight underestimate of about 10
percentage points but a majority of
respondents um or an on average
respondents thought that about 60
percent of women and child refugees were
women and children compared to the
actual percentage of 70 between 2015 and
2017.
there actually was not really an
overestimation of the percent that was
muslim so
looking at the years 2002 to 2016 on
average about 32 percent of refugees
admitted were muslim and the average yes
for our respondents was 28
this did drop under trump to 16 but i
think um in general this is pretty close
to what it was for a long period and
then there is a slight there is an
underestimate on how many uh christians
are admitted especially for that those
years from 20 2002 to 2016.
um
in terms of english fluency we asked
respondents to basically add up to 100
in terms of how many ref what percent of
refugees spoke english fluently when
they arrived spoke some english or spoke
no english and here respondents were
remarkably close at least on average
um so a slight overestimate actually of
how many speak english fluently on
arrival
and a slight underestimate of how many
peop how many speak no english
in terms of whether refugees pay taxes
um the modal answer was not sure but
moore said yes than no which is the
correct response
and so it's really when we get to these
security issues that we start to see
really large divergences from um what
the actual refugee population looks like
um
so
we asked people the percent of terrorist
attacks since 1980 for instance that
were conducted by refugees the actual
answer is zero um and the average
response here was 29 so this is a big
miss
we also asked uh respondents how many
months of vetting the typical refugee
goes through um the modal response was
six to 12 months the actual response the
actual answer is 18 to 24 months um and
this is also a pretty substantial
difference
in terms of the likelihood that refugees
would commit crime it's actually
most
respondents did acknowledge that it was
an equal likelihood and there is a bit
of a miss too on origin countries so
most said mexico and syria would provide
the most refugees in the year of the
survey when in fact it was the drc
burma and ukraine uh so there are
clearly misconceptions here some of this
information is
quite specific and you might not expect
everyone to know it but even in those
cases um
people are getting pretty close but what
we do seem to see is a big miss in terms
of how
much refugees are tied up into security
threats and so just to provide a little
more detail on that this is the
distribution of responses on
the months of vetting that refugees go
through so again the true answer is here
at 18 to 24 months
most of the distribution is quite a bit
lower than that
especially with the mode at 6 to 12.
and then again um there's a pretty big
miss in terms of the percent of
terrorist activity from 1980 to the
present conducted by refugees
so there are many people saying zero but
quite a few are way over estimating that
percent
and this is correlational so we can only
take so much from it
but there does there is some evidence
that those who miss on the security
threat
of refugees those who have the the
highest misconceptions here
are much less likely to have favorable
attitudes towards refugees as you might
expect
so in terms of the feeling thermometer
they're much less likely to rate
refugees warmly they're more likely to
also say that refugees might threaten
national identity increase the risk of
terrorism
um and are a burden on the us
we also in this survey um had a question
where respondents could donate money to
uh the refuge refugee council usa or
another pro-refugee group or um an
organization that's been active in
promoting stricter um limits on refugees
and again you see that individuals who
are more likely to hold this
misconception are much less likely to
donate to the pro-refugee groups and
then finally like also with policy
preferences um those who
believe that refugees don't go through
as much vetting or commit more terrorist
attacks
are more supportive of the muslim ban
want more screening want fewer refugees
so this is not conclusive this may be
reverse causation but it does suggest
that perhaps these security
misconceptions are related
to how people are developing their
attitudes towards refugees
in the united states
i see a hand
yeah i i was wondering about some of you
the um
some of the information that you uh
compared the attitudes to the the
factual information like for example
um
what struck me refugees
um
engaging in prime having equal likely
likelihood of engaging in crime and
you know i don't know that that you know
i've always heard
otherwise
and so and there were a couple of other
the things also
that you mentioned that seemed off the
mark but maybe i'm misinformed
so i was wondering where you got your
information from
yeah so we actually looked at a variety
of sources to make sure we we had this
right and frankly um several of these
answers i would not have known exactly
myself and so i think our idea here is
not that
not to show that you know this is a
fairly technical specific policy issue
and to say that people should know
exactly what percent of refugees are
women and children or um if refugees are
equally likely to commit crime or less
so or more so um but in general some of
these misconceptions if they're really
large might be contributing to how
people are
perceiving refugees as threats or not um
and so the fact that people on average
aren't so far off we thought was
positive for for some of these um i in
terms of the crime one specifically
there has been there have been recent
papers published looking at this
question with
pretty rigorous research designs and uh
basically what they're showing is that
as refugees come into an area um there's
a precisely estimated null effect on
crime rates increasing
i think this is pretty much the
conclusion from
other sources as well i don't remember
the exact citation but if you're
interested i can provide it to you
likewise with the women and children
muslim christian this we were taking
directly from u.s government statistics
um
online
thank you
yes i i have a question um also
i mean if this information is uh divided
by like uh political affiliation
and
also a bit related to that is that
i mean
i think it has become harder
um for people conducting surveys
to sort to get to the
the way people actually think if you are
uh as for example their voting behavior
i mean there have been quite uh some
mismatches on what
people say and what they actually do so
i wonder if some of the information that
you are getting yourself might
experience the same
problem as well
yeah that's absolutely a possibility so
um so your first part of the question
there are definitely differences here
for instance between republicans and
democrats
um
in
in estimating these
differences like differences on crime or
terrorist activity or how many refugees
are admitted or the women and children
etc um and part of that may be
um
answering in a way that justifies
more restrictive policies because you
prefer those restrictive policies and
then want to answer in a way that
um supports the policies whereas
democrats might do the opposite which is
that they
want more refugees admitted so even if
they don't know the answer they're going
to just guess a low number
on the terrorist activity question for
instance because that aligns with the
view they already hold so we're taking
an agnostic stance on whether this
information
is actually um reflects i guess you
could say their true beliefs um we did
not incentivize them to definitely get
it right we were just curious what they
would tell us
their conceptions were um
and that's somewhat relevant to what we
then do in the second study and how we
set up whether information provision can
actually reduce prejudice
because one of the reasons that
um
you know it may fail to have an effect
is because even if the information is
new and relevant people just aren't
processing it um
and we to preview a little bit that's
kind of what we find so even though
um
we basically update people in
montsetting and it doesn't seem to have
any spillover effects and that might
suggest that when people answer this
question they're just providing the
answer that already aligns with their
views
maybe they
have a sense of the truth and just don't
want to say it
or maybe they just don't care
and so
it could be it's probably the case that
some of these answers are
driven by other considerations uh
because again i wouldn't expect most
people to have thought
deeply about the specifics of these
issues that's probably asking too much
and so where they draw their priors on
are going to be informed by a bunch of
different sources
thanks
um so
and if there aren't other questions
there but although i'm happy to take
them i'll move on to the second study
uh again the idea here being that we
build from the first
um to try and see if correcting a
misconception that stands out in the
survey can have effects on attitudes
towards refugees so the structure of the
survey we first asked demographic
questions
um and then refugee security priors
again so we basically asked some of the
questions from the first survey that i
just talked about
we then try to measure baseline empathy
using a questionnaire from davis this is
an old source about how to measure
someone's general levels of empathy to
get at those heterogeneous treatment
effects i mentioned
and then we assign people to treatment
groups or control followed by
measurements of the outcomes
um so we have three treatment groups
here and a control group
so the first treatment and i'll talk
about these in more detail
is that correction on betting and
security checks specifically
the second is
providing a prospective getting
narrative about a refugee and the third
is simply combining those two treatments
together to see if there is a beneficial
interaction here
the control is is a pure control so
respondents don't get assigned to
anything and they just proceed through
the survey to the outcome questions
um so this is what the information
treatment looks like essentially we
chose to um focus on the vetting
misconception where people
are
underestimating how much
refugees go through security checks the
idea being here that we could provide
the most credible information to
respondents by
citing government sources directly
we thought this might have more weight
especially given that many of the
organizations mentioned have fairly high
levels of trust in the us
so we wanted to try and make this
treatment as strong as possible and
thought that this would be the way to do
it
um so first respondents are told that
they will read some information about
the u.s and that we would then have them
reflect on what they read
and the treatment itself on the next
page says according to us government and
non-governmental agencies refugees
undergo more extensive and thorough
screening than anyone else who travels
into the united states
biometric and medical data are collected
from the refugee who was screened by
you know then a whole host of security
oriented organizations
um the average time for the vetting
process is 18 to 24 months but it can
take even longer to view an infographic
of the process click here
and that would open into a new tab so
not many people actually clicked on it
this is just a little more information
about what we've already told them and
to give the source even more clearly if
they
were concerned about that
but
this is the information that most
respondents in this treatment group were
getting
and then for the second treatment group
we went with a perspective getting
narrative so the idea here is that you
take a narrative from an individual of
an out group and you
explain to people what it's like to be
in their shoes um give a personal story
about how hard it might be to be a
refugee coming to the united states
we chose to go with a hypothetical story
here and we told respondents that
because we didn't want them um we we
didn't want to
um essentially
use deception
um
but what we did and i'll talk about this
a little more is draw on real stories to
create this story the reason we wanted
to do the hypothetical was to have as
much control as possible over the
information
uh so we have this story about abdi um
who we say was once one of 26 million
refugees in the world
um he flees war-torn somalia at a young
age for kenya and then lives in a camp
for nine years
um he says it feels like a big jail cell
they give you food housing and the rest
will be from the hands of countries
coming to help people like america you
just pray to allah when am i going to
leave this place
we then talk about his experience in the
united states so how hard it was to um
to settle in
and explain his background to people
whether that's ramadan or eid
now he has a business he runs his own
accounting firm he does community
service and he likes music like led
zeppelin so the first part of this is to
try and give the experience of actually
being going through the refugee process
and the second then trying to integrate
and build a new life once you've
actually arrived
um
yeah again but by
putting i mean some
of the information that you put about
this hypothetical individual
aren't you already sort of
bringing up some of the
biases that people might have as well
and then so for example
i don't know one of the things that they
do in the
labor market is that they put anonymous
the the name because then if you
associate certain name with certain
characteristics of the people so
obviously here you want to
to get sort of the
more of empathy of what is the process
to go through but aren't you also sort
of as i said the people that are already
have their own biases bringing that or
people who have doubts about that
yeah that's definitely a possibility um
so
for instance saying that he's muslim um
there's lots of research showing that
people react more negatively to
immigrants who are non-christian
in the us that might prompt this
you mentioned the economic competition
that might also be the case but i think
what the prior research suggests is that
when you really humanize
people that often have
face negative stereotypes it seems like
on average this this is beneficial and
that is actually what we find
and on the hypothetical part um you know
if anything that might weaken the
treatment if they're like well this
isn't a real person why should i care um
so whereas the information treatment we
tried to make as strong as possible um
this one we actually were okay with it
potentially being weaker and that's
partly because previous literature shows
that this sort of approach is supposed
to be more effective and we were really
trying to see like can we make this
information provision helpful or not
um
and so i'll go into this a little more
the combined treatment essentially puts
in the information paragraph after the
part where andy's talking about
um how it was
how it was coming to the u.s how long he
had to wait this felt like a natural
point
and then proceeded again to what it was
like trying to integrate
um so again these are hypothetical
individuals but we did base these on
stories from real articles
there were two articles from the courier
journal in louisville um and then from
npr on
the first was about louisville
immigrants share stories of terror love
and courage on the road to america the
npr one muslims in america telling your
own stories and these articles are
essentially doing exactly
what our treatment is supposed to do
which is giving people this perspective
humanizing
both muslim americans and um immigrants
and we actually borrow real quotes from
these articles and real parts of the
stories so the led zeppelin part for
instance was one of these stories um the
quotes about waiting to come to the us
for all those years also were from one
of these stories going to somalia at a
young age losing parents
um and so you know we felt that that
would be most likely to generate this
empathy and humanize the individual
um but also to avoid deception and just
give credit to these articles we then
did have a debriefing statement at the
end uh just saying that you know you
read this story
this was based on real people if you
want to read more you can click here
so after respondents were assigned to
one of these three treatments or if
they're in the control group
sorry after they were assigned to these
three treatments we then ask them to
please write a short paragraph
summarizing what you just read and how
you feel about it
so we had two purposes to doing this the
first was
um we wanted people to actually think
about what they had just read we wanted
to make it as likely as possible that
they would really take that information
into account or really reflect on abby's
story and what that might mean for the
experience of being a refugee um
but the second um
reason also was because we wanted this
module
we wanted the treatments to feel like
they could have been their own modules
in the survey
that there was a question to be answered
about
reading the paragraph so that when
respondents then went on to the outcomes
it wasn't as obvious that they had just
read this story because we wanted them
to answer these subsequent questions so
we're trying to avoid demand effects
essentially by building in this question
to the treatments
um so after one of the treat after the
treatments or the if they're in the
control they go to a new page and they
have four outcome measures
so first do they actually update their
prior on the extensive nature of the
vetting process
um how warmly do they feel towards
refugees how many refugees do they want
to admit to the us
and then would they be willing to write
a letter to the president
about their
views on how many refugees should be
admitted so i'll go through each of
these and turn and then show the results
for for each of them as well so the
first question was again this ques
you know approximately how many months
of vetting does a refugee grow through
before being resettled in the united
states if you do not know please give
your best guess so this is a question
that we had asked on that very first
survey
we then ask it in the beginning of the
second survey and then we ask it again
in the end as part of the outcomes and
we want to see if people actually get
the answer right on the second time
and so this is what the the results look
like with the distributions of responses
um on the number of months for
the
initial answers and the pro the prior
sorry the prior answers and the
posterior answers after the treatments
um these are the three treatment groups
and this is the control so as you might
expect if there's no treatment the
respondents don't update at all why
would they um the answers are pretty
much identical
however if they receive the information
we give them they do correct quite a lot
um so now the distribution is centered
around um the correct answer and most of
um
most of that distribution is
on the correct answer
for the perspective getting treatment
only where they read abdi's story they
don't update at all even though um we
talk a little bit about how long he had
to wait to come
so what i will flag here is that we had
expected that people might become more
open to correcting their misconceptions
um if we embedded the information in
that
empathy empathy narrative and we don't
really see that um essentially the
effect here is the same
if the info is on its own or in
the narrative there's no added benefit
to
trying to combine the two
the second outcome is trying to broaden
out more getting closer to
prejudice or negative views of refugees
personally as people so we use a
standard feeling thermometer saying on a
scale from 0 to 100 where zero equals
completely unfavorable and 100 equals
completely favorable
how do you feel about refugees who come
to the united states
so here what we find is in the control
group an average response
of 62
and
providing that information about the
vetting process
doesn't really change this at all um
it's also 62.6
so we might have thought that
convincing people that refugees go
through this extensive
vetting
would make them less worried about
security threats and therefore they
might feel more warmly towards refugees
because they don't see them as
threatening anymore but in fact that
doesn't happen at all
there's no broader spillover of the
information
into these views of refugees
however these empathy narratives the
perspective getting treatments do raise
um the average feeling thermometer score
quite a lot so by an average of six
percentage points
on the scale from 62 to 68.5
and again this is pretty consistent
whether its perspective getting on its
own
or if that story about abdi is combined
with the information
and again we don't see any interaction
here where combining the two makes them
even more effective
the third outcome has to do with policy
preferences
um so we tell them every year the
federal government decides how many
refugees to allow to be resettled in the
united states
and we then give them some context so
they know what those numbers have looked
like and how much they've bounced around
we say this year the number of refugees
permitted to enter is 125 000 next year
do you think the number should be higher
lower
or stay the same
and so again information here providing
that correction on vetting
doesn't
doesn't make people more supportive of
admitting more refugees if anything
um there's actually a slight backlash
here although that is not statistically
significant
um however again giving the narrative
about abdi does seem to make people more
willing to say they would want to
increase the number of refugees admitted
that's significant and substantively
fairly meaningful
and again combining the two
doesn't really do much difference as we
thought it might
it's slightly higher
for the combination but that difference
is not significant
and then finally we ask would you be
willing to write a letter to the current
president's administration
advocating for your position on how many
refugees should be admitted into the
united states so they could say yes they
would like to write a letter supporting
an increase
yes they would like to write a letter
opposing an increase or no they would
not like to write a letter and if they
said yes in support or opposition
we ask them to actually write the letter
to make this as behavioral as possible
and we said um and we will send it
anonymously to the administration on
their behalf after completion of the
survey
so this is what the results look like
here and again they're quite consistent
where um correcting on vetting if
anything has a slight backlash although
again this is not significant um so
you're not seeing that spillover
however the perspective getting
treatments on their own and in
combination with the information
do
increase willingness to write a
supportive letter for raising the
refugee
cap so to summarize these main effects
of the treatments um we do find that
misconceptions on security threat can be
corrected um whether that's information
just on its own blandly provided or
whether that's embedded in a perspective
getting exercise
however that information on its own
doesn't really seem to improve attitudes
and behaviors relative towards the
control and recall here that we were
trying to pick a piece of information
where clearly people often have had it
wrong and where also it's it seems
theoretically and also from some of the
regression analysis we did that this
should be
related um to attitudes towards refugees
so we were trying to make this as strong
as possible
but still
it didn't really work beyond just
correcting the misconception that being
said of course it may well be that
another piece of information would have
been more effective and maybe we just
chose wrong
on the other hand we do find that
perspective getting on its own or with
information
really does improve attitudes and
behaviors at least in the context of the
survey um
making respondents more inclusive in how
they approach refugees as people and
also policies
however this doesn't actually cause them
to update their beliefs about the
vetting process
which is not necessarily surprising
so now i want to talk about
the heterogeneous treatment effects i
had mentioned
um in terms of whether that perspective
getting treatment specifically
is more or less likely to be effective
based on dispositional empathy
and so again it could be that those with
more empathy actually respond less well
to this treatment or that those with
more empathy respond better
because they're more capable of
processing the out group's perspective
and in fact what we see
for the three outcomes where the
perspective getting mattered um was that
these effects were much stronger among
individuals who had higher levels of
baseline empathy so in other words
people who are just generally better at
empathizing with others um
we were more likely to increase their
inclusive views in response to the
treatment than individuals who um just
for whatever reason are less empathetic
so this is what it looks like with the
feeling thermometer
um
among individuals who are below average
in their baseline empathy the feeling
the perspective getting exercise
with abdi increased the average response
on the thermometer by about four
percentage points
however among those um with a higher
level of baseline empathy
the average on the thermometer almost
doubled
the treatment effect almost doubled um
to eight percentage points so
uh this difference is significant and
fairly large
uh
so
scott are these um
results sort of um
do do they
are they the same by gender or by other
characteristics of uh
they say
are they still
so obviously find the same level of
positive for example you would find that
one is
more than steel
so i believe we've looked with
partisanship and it
doesn't seem to
differ consistently um
and
likewise i'm not sure about gender but
that would be a good one for us to look
at
um there definitely may be
other heterogeneous effects here that
we want to look at
but this pattern does hold with controls
included so
um
it seems you know it seems like as as
well as we can do since we're not
randomly assigning levels of empathy
um that this pattern does persist
um
and i guess for me partly it's quite
strong because it's consistent across
those three outcomes so this is what it
looks like for
the policy outcome where
you actually see a slightly
negative effect for those low in empathy
for the combined treatment although not
significant
but you see quite large effects and
positive effects
um for those high in empathy
and then again also with letter writing
there's a slight boost for those low and
baseline empathy but
um there's a fairly large boost for
those higher in baseline empathy so
you know when when we're doing this
analysis it may be that there's some um
other omitted variable explaining the
heterogeneous effects
we can't rule that out but it seems like
on average those with
a higher capacity to empathize with
others in general are the ones who are
most likely to be
affected by treatments that try to prime
empathy and i do think logically that
makes sense um
and and isn't so surprising so
practically that might suggest that
these are the kinds of people to target
with these
exercises when you're designing
messaging
so
just to start wrapping up in terms of
implications um
there is some debate over whether
trying to
reduce prejudice generally or change
attitudes on refugees and immigration is
better served by doing this sort of
information correction
or by trying to leverage empathy about
specific people and their stories and
and our study
is not the first to show but builds on
others suggesting that these empathy
generating treatments
are more effective um
typically than trying to correct
people's
stereotypes or falsely held beliefs
but again those effects seem to be
stronger for
those with high baseline empathy and in
fact
they may
not exist at all for those who are lower
on average and empathizing with others
at the same time we do show that
correcting misconceptions is possible so
when we told people that
the us government does all this
extensive betting there wasn't that much
resistance to them
agreeing with that information is and
updating their priors and saying okay
yeah um i had it wrong this is how much
vetting they actually go through so to
the extent that we care about correcting
misinformation um
even if we're not showing in this study
that that has spillover effects in other
ways that we might care about it does
still seem that it is possible to get
people to update on these sorts of
issues even when they're closely tied to
pretty touchy political topics and
debates
and
to us the main takeaway here is that
interventions combining perspective
getting more perspective taking
along with information correcting
misconceptions may be the most effective
at addressing a range of outcomes
because even though we didn't find an
interaction as we were expecting where
these treatments became more effective
by combining them together
the combined treatment was the one that
corrected people's misconceptions and
also had these effects on prejudice
through the perspective getting
narrative um so this may have practical
implications for messaging that's
emphasized by advocates
if you're going to provide information
and updates
uh try to update people's priors you
might want to work in these humanizing
stories along with it um
if your goal ultimately is to increase
support for admitting refugees
alongside correcting those
misconceptions likewise
if you're going to humanize
refugees as part of a prejudice
reduction strategy then you might also
try and work in information
make the most of addressing as many
outcomes as possible
in terms of where we go next um so
we would like to think more about
heterogeneous effects and do some
exploratory analysis in thinking about
who these interventions work best for
uh we're only showing this short term in
the survey so it may be that these
effects dissipate pretty quickly in fact
they probably do
uh so we may try to look at persistence
and then potentially we'd be interested
in trying to scale this up into
an experiment experiment with actual
messaging in the field so that's
potentially another step also so if
there are comments or suggestions
along those lines um
i'd be happy to hear them
so yeah i'll end there thank you very
much comments are welcome you can also
email me directly
um here and for the team of co-authors
we do have a nascent website that you're
welcome to look at as well um at this
link thank you
yeah uh thanks i'm trying to remember
exactly um
for your first experiment the what
exactly how you gave uh the information
concerning the misconceptions and again
i'm thinking about crime versus refugee
uh vetting
is you know what is the the distribution
of those misconceptions and so i'm
wondering why you took refugee vetting
for your second experiment
and if there's something to learn from
doing um
doing the experiment on
a misconception that is not um
i don't know that is not uh
the average misconception but where
there is a lot of variety in what that
misconception is
so getting at some of the heterogeneous
effects probably
yeah so for the
for the first study um we simply asked
people
to
try and describe refugees in terms of
these characteristics sort of one by one
as questions throughout the survey so we
didn't randomize anything here we
weren't trying to incentivize getting
the answer right um we just
asked them to you know say
give us please give us your best guess
for what percent of women and children
are um
sorry what percent of refugees are women
and children so we and we also we we
told people explicitly like if you don't
know just try to give your best guess so
there we were just interested in seeing
generally what the misconceptions might
be and for many of these answers there
is a lot of variation so
this for instance is the percent of
terrorist activity conducted by refugees
uh someone is saying 100
i like to believe that that is an effort
a political statement but maybe not but
clearly there's a lot of um
variation here that could be
played around with and i do think if we
replicate a version of this study it
might make sense to use this
misconception for instance instead of
the betting one to see how this looks
with
a slightly different piece of
information that in some ways may be
even more direct in terms of what people
are worried about um
so
i do think it would be valuable to play
around with different
types of corrections because again one
weakness of this
literature generally is that there are a
million different ways that you can
provide information correcting different
misconceptions um
and it's hard you know we can think
through theoretically why certain
information might be better than
than others but um
it may just be that this was the wrong
piece to update people on so that is
definitely a consideration to
to keep in mind
thank you
would you be trying or is it
part of
the
exercise maybe
going forward and also to identify
the people that are
more sort of
have more empathy because obviously then
you can sort of increase whatever
policy you're trying to do but i i would
not know how to do that i don't know if
you have talked about that
yeah that's
that's a great suggestion we haven't i
guess thought about that so
directly we have
analyzed the correlates of
higher or lower baseline empathy um
i am not remembering those precisely so
i don't want to say something that might
end up being incorrect but we have
looked at that and you can definitely
say like so-and-so is more likely to
have
a high level of empathy um
but
thinking through
perhaps how to identify people with more
empathy in groups that aren't known for
it might be
fruitful for instance um so that's
something that seems worth thinking
about
and what about the characteristics of
the individual like i think when i'm
trying to convince oh yeah i don't like
to be called chairman of my department
and how what would you think if your
daughter was
uh you know heading in economics
department and she were called chairman
and it's because i can
appeal
to
that characteristic of him being a
father to a daughter
and so what can you do potentially in
terms of learning how to
correct these misconceptions
and appealing to that
so one um
in our previous work looking at family
history we essentially try to do that
because
basically all americans
come from elsewhere
not all but most
you can draw on that as a sort of shared
identity or experience at some point in
your family's past that people can
relate to and we show that this might
increase empathy towards
immigrants coming in today
so i i definitely agree that
being able to link um
your own experience to something they've
gone through themselves or at least
tangentially are related to perhaps
because their daughter
um has faced gender discrimination and
they've seen it even if they're a man
who can't go through it
then that will be perhaps more effective
um as
as an intervention on that type of
person because they're just more able to
relate so that may be the case even for
people who don't have high levels of
baseline empathy
if you can still find a way to
link
the treatment to something they have
gone through personally
they may be more able to empathize than
with the target because they have some
sense of what it is like
um to go through that
and so in our earlier study we actually
don't find heterogeneous effects based
on baseline empathy and i think that's
in part because
um even those individuals
have this fam shared family history of
at some point migrating to the united
states
yeah
they still say but my family stood in
line
it doesn't work
that's the that's the response that they
always say
yeah they're not standing in line today
but they did back then my family did
yeah absolutely even though they didn't
right yeah we know they didn't you know
yeah
definitely got those responses as well
but on average
it seemed to have some positive effect
i just have
one comment so is that we're running a
survey about the seminars that
we
have
offered for this academic year so if
people could just please uh
complete it and send it to us so then we
can prepare for next year
and
so thank you very much to professor
scott williamson to for this wonderful
presentation and
just sort of to broaden
the possibilities that we have in order
to
change the
perspective of people about refugees so
thank you very much everyone and this is
our last seminar
of the
academic year any questions just
thank you
thank you